country so i'm a full-time musician i
want to work
so i joined a country band and um i was
only black guy in the band and usually
one of the few black guys who would be
in the in the clubs you know where we
would play
you play piano
and um the band was established in the
area
they've been around for a while uh i you
know i i'd met them recently and i
joined
and so uh we played a place called the
silver dollar lounge
which is in a town called frederick
maryland which is about an hour outside
of dc
and the silver dollar lounge was an
all-white bar
not meaning that black people or anybody
else couldn't go in
but black people were not welcome there
so they did not go in
and it's not a good idea to go somewhere
when you're not welcome and alcohol is
being served
you know it's not a good combination so
here i was in the silver dollar lounge
with this band
now they'd played that before i'd never
been there
so we came off the bandstand after the
first set
and to take a break and i'm walking to
go sit at the band table
and i felt some guy from behind put his
arm around my shoulder now i don't know
anybody in this joint right
and i see the whole band up ahead of me
so who is this person touching me
i turn around to see as a white guy you
know a little bit older than me well
a good i'd say maybe 15 years older than
me
and he says man i sure enjoyed your
all's music i said thank you
i shook his hand i said i appreciate
that and he pointed at the stage and
says
i've seen this here banned before but i
never seen you where'd you come from
and i explained i just joined the band
but yes he probably did see them because
they told me you know they played here
before
and it was an all-white band he says
well man i sure like your piano playing
you know this is the first time i've
ever heard a black man play piano like
jerry lee lewis
and um you know i wasn't offended but i
was rather surprised
that this guy being as old as he was
did not know the origin of jerry lee
lewis's style of piano playing right
and i and i was and i wasn't trying to
be facetious but i said
well where do you think jerry lee lewis
learned how to play he says were you
talking about
i said jerry lee learned it from the
same place i did from black
blues and boogie woogie piano players
that's where rockabilly and rock and
roll came from right
oh no no no generally invented that i
never seen no black man play like
he invented it yeah he invented it right
exactly
and so i i assured the guy you know this
wasn't the case
i said look man i said i know jerry lee
lewis jerry lee is a good friend of mine
i said he's told me himself where he
learned how to play guy didn't believe i
knew jerry lee he didn't believe jury
learned anything from black people
but he was fascinated enough with me
that he wanted to buy me a drink want me
to go back to his table
now i don't drink alcohol but i went
back to his table i ordered a cranberry
juice he paid the waitress
he takes his glass and he clinks my
glass and cheers me
and then he says you know this is the
first time i ever sat down and had a
drink with a black man
and now i'm like totally mystified
because i mean again i was not offended
but i'm just
curious because that was not my world
you know in my world at that point in my
life
i had sat down literally with
thousands of white people or anybody
else and had
a meal a beverage a conversation how is
it this guy who's older than me
has been around longer than i have had
never sat down with a black guy before
so now i'm genuinely curious and i said
why
he like he like looked at me they looked
down at the table top i asked him again
i said why
he's still looking at the tabletop his
buddy said tell him tell him tell him
elbowed him right i said tell me because
now i'm really curious and he says
i'm a member of the ku klux klan i burst
out laughing
i just busted out laughing and
because i thought the guy was joking you
know
i have every book on the clan as i told
you i've read them all
and none of my books talk about how a
klansman will come up and embrace a
black guy and want to hang out and buy
him a drink
it doesn't work that way right so you
know this guy there's no way this guy's
in the clan
while i'm laughing he goes inside his
pocket pulls out his wallet
and flips through it and hands me his
clan membership card
i instantly recognize the clan insignia
which is a red circle with a white cross
and a red blood drop in the center of
the cross and i realize oh
this thing is for real and i stopped
laughing it wasn't funny then
and i gave it back to him and we talked
about the clan and some other things
really yeah and uh you know he was very
friendly
very friendly and so um
he gave me his phone number and he
wanted me to call him whenever i was to
return
to this bar the silver dollar lounge
with this band
because he wanted to bring his friends
meaning klansmen and clans women
to come see the black guy who plays
piano like jerry lee i was a novelty to
him
that freaked you out when he said
something like that like this clans this
clan guy wants to bring all of his
friends to watch me
doesn't that make you like uh maybe i
don't want to talk to this guy
when he first showed me the card i was a
little stunned like you know what the
hell am i doing sitting here at the
table
with a klansman but he was so friendly
and this was your first time meeting an
actual clansman no my first time meeting
a klansman i beat him up
what yeah i beat him up i'll tell you
that's throwing a man okay
um so this guy was like super friendly
and um you know so it it
i i didn't have any fear of him in other
words right okay so i said okay i'll
call you
and we were on on like a rotation with
other bands every six weeks we know we
would appear there
you know friday and saturday the weekend
and i called him like on a wednesday
or thursday and said hey man you know
we're gonna be down at the silver dollar
come on out
he'd come both nights friday and
saturday he bring different clan people
and uh they you know watch they'll
gather around near the bandstand and
watch me play
and then they get out there and dance
and on the brick
you know i'd always stop by his table
say hello to him and
some of these clansmen and clans women
would hang there you know they were
curious you know they want to meet me
and so i talked to them but others would
see me coming on the break
and that i get up and scoot across the
room it was like you know they didn't
want anything to do with me just to
just to watch me but they didn't want to
interact with me right so you know it's
okay
so this went on until about to the end
of that year
and then i quit the band
and i went back to playing rock and roll
and other genres of music
and uh you know i i moved away from the
from the country scene
so i really had no reason to stay in
contact with him i lost touch with the
guy and
much much later it dawned on me daryl
you blew it man
the answer to your question that's been
plaguing you
since age 10 how can you hate me when
you don't
even know me the answer fell right into
your lap and you didn't even realize it
who better to ask that question of than
someone who would go so far
as to join an organization that has a
over a hundred year history
of practicing hating people that don't
look like them
and who don't believe as they believe
get back in touch with that guy
and get him to fix you up with the plan
leader for the state of maryland
start there interview that guy you know
and then go up north go down south
go to the midwest go to the west and
interview different clan leaders and
different members
and find out the answer to this question
and write a book there have been no
books written by black authors
on the ku klux klan from the perspective
of sitting down
face to face with them and interviewing
them wow there have been two books
written
uh by black authors dealing with the
clan but each one detailed
how he escaped the lynching one in the
1930s
and one in the 1940s but not from
talking with their would-be lynchers
right
so um fortunately i
i still had that guy's number i found it
i called it been disconnected
took me two weeks to track him down
turns out he had moved
and he didn't have a phone but he had an
address so i said okay i'm gonna go pay
him a visit
but i had no way of um you know letting
him know i'm coming over because he
didn't have a phone
so um i stopped by this apartment we
know where i was told he lived
one evening knocking on the door he
opens the door
he's like daryl what are you doing here
man he like steps out into the hallway
he like looks up and down the hallway to
see if i brought anybody with me
well when he stepped out of his
apartment i stepped into it
so he turns around he comes back in he
goes what's going on man are you still
playing what's going on
i said yeah yeah i'm still playing i
said but i need to talk to you
about the clan he says the klan i said
yeah you're a member right
was where i was and then he went into
this long dissertation which is pretty
funny too
uh as to why he had quit the clan
and um and what actually happened was he
had gotten banished
he got kicked out banished yeah they
they called it a banishment
yeah so he had been banished from the
clown you get kicked out
uh i'll tell you i'll tell you that in a
second too it's pretty funny but he said
that he quit
um but because uh they you know that he
came to find out that they didn't
believe in the
and the true christian things that he
believes